bill nye has worked for decades to get
audiences excited about science there's
Coke in there and when ultrasonics John
ultrasonics we're gonna coconut
resigning I left a print engineering to
bring his signature blend of Education
comedy to Seattle TV show where he
regularly conducted wacky experiments he
later hosted the popular influential
Bill Nye the Science Guy I covered
everything from atoms to the atmosphere
and 119 Emmys along the way he since
become an outspoken advocate for science
and the urgent need to tackle climate
change now is written a new book
everything all at once how to unleash
your inner nerd tap into radical
curiosity and solve any problem that's a
long title
Bill Nye people who know how to read so
your message is tap into your curiosity
about science because so we can change
the world for the better that everybody
has something they're passionate about I
claim I bet your storytelling is one of
your things and so by getting that same
energy well I think we can leave the
world better than we found it
what we should say listen you've been a
nerd for a long time liza was saying in
the green room that you wear it proudly
that word on you in high school was a
party doesn't start until bill takes out
the dictionary you were a fun guy back
then tell me about it
listen we are the caretakers of the
earth this stuff really does matter that
week we have the ability to shape and
improve the world we can do that as
human beings well so everybody it's
important to keep in mind right now
humankind moves more soil and rock than
nature does our influence on the earth
is extraordinary and so along with that
comes a responsibility everybody
the reason the climate is changing is
because of humans and so we want to take
responsibility for that and we'll make
the world better for everybody
other countries more curious about
science than we are right now yeah but
still it's this thing where the very
best of the best or really good research
is done the United States at very high
level we want to engage everybody that
we lose that if we could somehow
lost our well sure I mean if you like to
worry about things you're living at a
great time but what's the beauty of
being a nerd because most people in high
school and even in life today normally
isn't something they aspire to but you
say listen nerds change the world
nerds are better listeners nerds are
better learners and nerds really pay
attention to the do you think Bill Gates
or Mark Zuckerberg yeah yeah well so all
these people that we admire right now
you said Gates Zuckerberg Elon Musk
these people are generally engineers or
physics majors what have you not not not
Mark Zuckerberg or Bill Gates they were
they wrote code they saw they wrote
logical problems yeah I mean writing
computer code is akin to mathematics
akin to engineering but what is it about
the nerd brain no bill that you think is
something that we should all try to
strive for well just it's solving
problems by thinking rationally about
problems you enables you to get better
answers than just relying on your
instincts here's a really good example
the health care debate we just had a
discussion earlier today about the
politics of the health care debate
there's all this fascinating science
going on about reducing health care
costs whether it's using apps
preventative medicine and that's not
anywhere in the political or discussion
in Washington oh yeah so everybody one
of the things I talk about in the book
is the upside-down pyramid of design
right what happens at the beginning
changes everything so the health care
debate I will say as a citizen we are
looking at two different views one is
let's provide health care to as many
people as we can afford the other one is
let's provide health care to everyone
it's almost the same but not quite the
same so if you start with those two
different ideas you're gonna have a lot
of trouble so yeah the technology to
save healthcare to reduce healthcare
costs is available and by the way you
have to protect the internet you have to
protect electronic information if we're
going to rely on it in this
extraordinary way the way we do today
and that is also a solvable problem
everybody it's not okay to be hacking
the internet that's not good
and so this is we can do this but what
you talked about it seems to me it's not
so much science but per se but it is the
creativity of problem-solving well and
also believing that you can solve the
problem this is one of the premise in
science everybody so far is that we can
know nature that we can understand
things if you go into it we can't figure
this out we can't possibly then you
won't and so it gets back to when they
are that you're concerned about climate
change why do you think there's such e
so many people are reluctant to accept
what they others believe science tells
them wow it's just closing your eyes to
a situation you do not wish to
acknowledge and also you guys for you
conspiracy buffs there's been
extraordinary effort by the fossil fuel
industry to suppress the facts of
climate change but our claim in the
engineering side is that we there is
enough energy in sunlight wind and a
little bit of geothermal a little bit of
tidal energy to run the whole place
right now renewably if we just decided
to do it and would I tell everybody my
grandfather went into World War one on a
horse he rode a horse I guess he was not
the world's greatest horseman but he did
it he lived through it rode around at
night around trenches in the dark but
nobody rides a horse now for for a
living why is it by the way is quite a
horse woman yeah woman I went to high
school with who is your sketcher artist
people don't get around New York City on
horses everything changed in two decades
so let's change everything we can do
this people everybody you meet know
something that you don't that is the key
that you should consider everything all
at once but you can't process everything
all know there's this idea of
multitasking I'm not really so sure
about it you do one thing at a time but
you look at the big picture Charlie says
everybody's better wearing a bowtie that
is a badge of honor that's right you
look better wearing a big do not they do
not slip into the soup P do not flop
into you my friend Eric Kandel who won a
Nobel Prize wears a red bowtie
coincidence yeah
nice I thought you'd like that to pay
for later and thank you very much and
don't forget the Eclipse is coming up
everybody it's kind of a
once-in-a-lifetime thing world's third
most populous country get out there and
get under it very much totality August
21st thank you bail everything all at
once goes on sale tomorrow wherever you
like to buy your books